this is why my little raven brain love sterling silver
because I got these hoop earrings
so awesome got them like this vintage from eBay
I just cleaned it
hello hello
do you see that difference
I this is like
I just love that you can just always make sterling silver look brand new with
here's what I use
wrights silver cream
this is how much I've used
I like I clean the shit out of my Sterling silver
um and this is also like
so fun and like
relaxing for me cause I love doing things with my hands
um but this is why I love Sterling silver because like
you can just like
make old things new again
and I just find so much satisfaction in that
um so yeah
wait I'll show you how I clean this
okay so I get a little bit honestly
you're supposed to use
like a rag
I use my thumb with my fucked up nail
um and I like
dig into it
and then I just rub it on here
and make sure that the whole earring is coated again
would this be better with like
a cloth for the entire thing
yeah this is my little
I have like actually a little white cloth
and you just buff it
just like
buff the oxidation off
um
she's already coming off
clean clean clean
buffing and cleaning
buffing and cleaning Whoo
doing your finger gives you more control of the places that need the cream
I guess
do do
do do cleaning
cleaning cleaning
do do do do do
do do do clean clean clean clean clean clean cleaning cleaning cleaning
this is me cleaning
do do do do do do
okay so this is the finished product
like like
they look so good
are you kidding me
anyways I love sterling Silver
and I feel pretty